welcome back to how to lose a billion
dollars with future now last time we
left off optimism was high the company
was doing great future net was at its
peak
[Music]
and she's out of
[Music]
but things are about to take a turn for
the worse and know by worse I don't mean
that I'm talking about the fall of you
tonight
now it's hard to exactly pinpoint where
future debt started falling apart but
some people would say it's when ad pro
2.0 came out and as part of that they
shut down the system for development for
a very long time and just stopped paying
people all together now obviously not
paying people what you owe them has a
way of injecting cynicism into your
ecosystem but another big thing that
happened was one of their top promoters
Ryan Connolly really had a falling-out
with the company they accused him of
cross promoting other schemes and scams
to their users now it's important to
know who he is because we're gonna be
talking a lot about Ryan so as a way of
introduction here's Ryan introducing
future net to a bunch of people in
Africa it will save all of Africa with
you guys knowing about what we're
bringing so you do not have to live here
anymore so you guys have food for your
children okay
yes that's Ryan Conley shushing people
and telling them that their poverty is
no more they can leave Africa once they
join future now so you do not have to
live here anymore now Ryan's really
interesting because he's sort of a breed
of a guru that we have not talked about
before he's not a member of future net
by any means in the official sense but
he's what we might call a promoter of
schemes and scams on his YouTube and
Facebook he's constantly promoting new
schemes to be a part of and he's just
always hopping from one thing to another
so after cross promoting a bunch of
other scams to his followers on future
net Ryan is actually kicked out of
future net because they said they can't
have people cross promoting on their
platform and Ryan goes off and it's war
you were the one that started this war
and I'm gonna finish it and he admits
several really huge things the first
accusation he makes is that the purpose
of future Nets foundation is just to
appease the conscience of Roman and
Stefan because they felt bad about how
much
they were making you told me directly
that the only reason why the future that
foundation was created was to make
Stefan Morgenstern and Romans Eemian
feel good about the amount of money that
they have made
how how pathetic is that whoa that's a
big accusation I wonder who he's gonna
report them to do you have any idea when
this information is presented to the
United Nations think do you not think
that I have you guys have never even
been to the United Nations at all hey
you guys in the comments right now I bet
you guys have never even been to the
United Nations I bet that's how
sophisticated you got shows that you
know the second thing we learned is that
Ryan basically admits that the business
model is unsustainable do you really
think this is a business model that's
gonna last forever you have another
thing coming and this is the same guy
who's telling a group of people in
Africa that you know this business
models is gonna save them from hunger so
you guys have food for your children
okay there is a new Facebook people if
you use it the Facebook that pays the
people and by the way we don't just get
admissions in this rant we also get some
pretty hilarious moments one of which is
Ryan supposedly knowing the art of war
and so you don't want to go go to go to
war against Ryan I've listened to the
art of war all day long and I would not
engage word against you honestly because
you are the if I do not think I could
win I am throwing my sword up you just
like the gladiator movie are you
entertained yes yes we are we are very
entertained another thing Ryan Connelly
accuses future net of is actually
embezzling money from their customers
and kicking people out and taking over
their accounts and taking the money and
misappropriating those funds I want them
to return the millions of dollars that
they have stolen I have proof that these
accounts of these millionaires within
future who have been terminated that
they have actually switched out the
information the Bitcoin wallet addresses
of these accounts that they have stolen
they have switched out the email address
future that has done this and they are
always drawing the money
out of these accounts and is going to
other things we have this all documented
this was all the beginning of the end
now even though Ryan Connolly would
eventually make amends with the leaders
at future net and go back to like kind
of promoting them it was all over
warnings from Poland which is where
Stefan and Roman were based started
coming out about this Ponzi scheme and
as of 2020 the company's basically done
they haven't totally admitted defeat but
nobody's posting to their YouTube
channel anymore Stefan and Roman have
basically ghosted everyone and nobody's
really getting paid their total collapse
is all but certain now from this point I
feel like there are three really
important questions to answer which is
what happens to all the people involved
we really have three distinct parties
here we have promoters like Ryan
Connelly what happens to them when
something like this happens we have
stefan and roman the founders what
happened to them and we also have
basically everyone else the real victims
of this entire thing the aftermath for
Ryan Connelly is basically nothing he's
just gonna jump on to the next gimmick
scam whatever you want to call it and
he's gonna promote that until that runs
into the ground and then he's gonna
promote something else Stefan and Roman
are fine as well they have loads of
money now and this really wasn't even
their first scam Stephan Morgenstern he
promoted something called one line
online before this where he took a bunch
of people's money my name is Stefan
Moulton stem I am from Germany yes and
I'm 23 years in the network marketing
industry and this was just another in a
long line of scams not to say that they
aren't in a little bit of trouble though
they're under investigation in Poland
and according to reports have fled the
country using Gambian passports to lay
low for a while but all things
considered because this is sort of an
international crime where most of the
victims are poor people who don't have
money to sue him they're probably gonna
be fine honestly the real victims are
everyone else everyone who actually
bought into this company I joined a
class-action lawsuit chatroom in order
to try to talk to some of these victims
and their stories are absolutely
horrifying future net has absolutely
ruined people's lives whether people
invested
some money small amounts of money a lot
of the effects on people's lives were
absolutely devastated
this guy deposited seventy thousand
euros right as the bubble started to
burst with future net and he says it
affected his relationships and ruined
his wife's trust in him
this victim lost three hundred dollars
which may not sound like a lot but he's
from a country where the hourly wage is
thirty cents which means according to
him that $300 was eight months of his
savings that he lost and some people it
didn't just affect monetarily reports of
suicide started coming out from Korea
and there was a person in the chat room
from Thailand who had two members of her
team commit suicide as well this was
absolutely devastating to people's lives
now unfortunately I wish I could tell
you that future net was unique it's not
Ponzi schemes are super common right now
especially in poor countries where
people are desperate to find a way to
get ahead and sadly the promise of free
money is a tempting one especially when
made from promoters like Ryan Connelly
who can make these things sound like a
sure thing it will save all of Africa
with you guys knowing about what we're
bringing so you do not have to live here
anymore so you guys have food for your
children okay
sadly however it's not and most of these
people are like sheep being led to the
slaughter the real wolves are the
founders of these companies who end up
absconded with a bunch of the money and
people like Ryan Connolly who just
jumped from that platform to the next
platform the next thing that they're
gonna promote pushing more and more
people into these disasters now it's not
to say that people like Ryan Connelly
the people pushing these big scams are
necessarily malicious about it but their
actions have terrible consequences
because actually Ryan was actually the
one who started the future net class
action lawsuit chatroom and tried to
organize people together so I consider
that to be a good thing but at the same
time in this chatroom where all these
victims are all these people that maybe
he brought into the company that ended
up losing all this money Ryan decides
that you know it may be time for a new
opportunity I've been working on this
project
have identified a technology using
augmented reality that could really make
us a legitimate business opportunity and
make things right with everyone so I
hope you guys do not feel that this is
out of place for me to share the
information down below and at 3:00 p.m.
today I have a phone call with the
augmented reality team vapor
technologies out of California
spelled va PR and this would be the
perfect fit to replace future ad Pro and
in the video it'll explain the rest of
this what is possible and so the cycle
begins again I hope that how to lose a
billion dollar series has served as sort
of a guide and a warning to those of you
considering joining a Ponzi scheme
because the truth is they can look super
compelling they can be paying out people
for years in fact I talked to one future
net victim who brilliantly explains why
future net caught up so many people into
its web people people put in like crazy
amounts because future net ran
successfully for like four years before
it fell so after like two two and a half
years also the skeptical people were
like yo its Ronnie so let's go in all in
and people put so much money into it
that's right
skeptical people end up getting taken in
because these things last just long
enough to overcome your skepticism you
may not understand how it works but who
cares because it's paying out exactly
until it doesn't anymore and everyone
loses their money I hope you guys stay
safe from scams like this this is far
from the last one and crypto scams are
popping up left and right please save
your money and as always don't forget to
smash like and subscribe thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
fail sucker
[Music]